this is winter forecast forecast calls
for a future I apologize if it's really
dark by the way I like the sun's just
starting to go down this last what we're
doing today um but uh ya know it's a
interesting episode actually the fine
thing at least 100 percent less Lars and
Renault that is true um this is a 2-1 I
saw the first half of Attic on and I had
to go to a panel and it's funny I'm glad
I said all the way through it because
when I saw the beginning of it this time
I'm like now this one this is just one
of those different alternative universe
from Ola run whatever I there's um I'm
gonna skip back good back and this is
because I'm like I'm here you're back
here or you need the scoop for that's
net I'll get whatever um and I'm glad
all the way through because I actually
do like that ending with them they see
all the different versions that could
happen and then they make the right
choice which is to leave way earlier
which I think what's actually I would
like to have a little something bad
happened I don't like to every single
solitary thing that could go right went
right oh no I liked a little something
that wasn't there but we don't know what
happened after they were staring outside
the window I mean maybe a tree crash
baby honey honey passed out I you know
and I like the fainting Connie tries to
kiss Stephen the parents see it flip the
outs and the mountain to the cold
midnight maybe that it sounds that um
but yeah I felt like I like effect at
attending like I was kind of waiting for
like just the emotional music or them so
like a chore smiley I said but I like
it's just very quiet and she just sort
of sits down and they both look and they
see the snow and stuff like that they
both get to watch the snow in a Schmo
I'm assuming that's what that was you
know again it could be like oh you don't
know if you was leading to but it's like
I'm assuming cuz they said they wanted
to snow yeah that that's what that was
about
um but yeah and I liked you think it's
something with like whatever the cape or
whatever the back of his outfit but it's
not it's that kind of gives them that
that future vision for a bit um and
yeah I kind of like that teaches them to
be a little bit more responsible as
well.this choices and but again that's
what bothers me is that a lot you know
some good but a lot of bad stuff well
now you can make the right choice I
would have liked it the right choice was
more resulting a little more negative
bothers you that bothers you and yet
what doesn't bother you is the fact that
Stevens Dan has a sunburn in winter when
it's 9:00 where did he get the sunburn
from I think it's just permanently but
I'm telling I think it's a I guess I was
about something on this job somehow it's
winter and it's snowing why does he
still have a summer what is this man's
problem frostbite
I know it's just lack oh oh yeah I guess
that's right um snow burn I fell when
the Sun hits the snow reflects back up
and you can still technically get a
sunburn in winter yes technically you
can but that's just beer um so yeah I
mean it's it it's a fine episode um I I
do find myself at you later than the
last my I feel like there's a
bait-and-switch that happens you get a
really really good one and the next
one's kind of like yeah and then you get
one second right yeah means I guess we'd
be due for another really good one and
then another and then those are I did
see there's one carbon madness you know
right I'm just I saw been like oh my
gosh you don't you have nothing to the
game but I'll just so cool back to the
old NES days um but uh ya know I do find
that when I see it's an episode with
Steve and Connie it's like I do
I'm liking those more and more there's
something about like they do share this
really legit a very kind yeah it's super
cute I think go ahead um and uh yeah
some can't think it too much else to say
about this oh look so red yeah I know
it's the expire tried to do the indoor
exposure we look to blue the outside
look to red so I try doing in between
it's still too red it's it's probably
gonna be super grainy too so I'm sorry
about that
now you look like a sunburned shaved
woodchuck I look like Stevens dad
basically um but I feel like this is a
good episode to put on if there actually
was like a snowstorm outside or some oh
yeah this was things cuz I could biomat
the fire yeah and then the the snow
outside so you can feel like it you're
safe inside it's like the previous one I
would totally watch around Halloween we
actually I wouldn't cuz it has both Mars
and Ronaldo yeah if it didn't have those
but is truly scary for that reason yeah
Oh buzz uh film yeah I kind of like it
when uh when a show captures like a
season or like you know I be that's
obviously winter and it's a storm and
stuff like that like you said I like
when you can see is we do go together it
miss fee but yelling you can heal the
weather Oh like you said I really like
something that does that literally
atmosphere yes so um
yes about a got anything else on it or
no honestly my voice is kind of given
yeah I feel like I know if I'm coming
down with a cold or something but yeah
so I'm actually trying not to talk and I
I don't have a ton to say like this is
probably a good episode of closeout yeah
I agree
um so uh cuckoo we will see you at the
next one take care whoo-hoo indeed